tensions are growing over european
military interventions in mali france
and germany consider withdrawing troops
after the country's junta ordered danish
soldiers to leave so who will fill the
security void this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nick clark a decade of european
military interventions in mali is
starting to unravel last week the
military government in bamako ordered
danish soldiers to leave immediately now
it's expelled the french ambassador to
mali after what the junta called hostile
and outrageous comments by france's
foreign minister johnny vladriya said
the military junta that took power after
two coups was illegitimate and out of
control and he criticized the presence
of a russian private military
contractors from the wagner group
adriana accused the mercenaries of
exploiting mali's resources in exchange
for protecting the gender here's some of
what he said
our will is intact it's not one event of
your responsibility i repeat my words
due to the illegitimacy of the coup
d'etat government that will halt our
fight against terrorism mali is so
isolated today that they only have one
partner the mercenaries of the wagner
group that's all they can find the only
partner today of mali is wagner everyone
else wants molly to return to democracy
and fight against terrorism
well drea adrian says that france is
holding talks with european and african
partners on whether to stay in mali
germany's commitment is also in doubt in
a newspaper interview its foreign
minister asked whether the conditions
for a successful military mission are
still in place but the army is staying
put for now
achieving our goals is only possible in
a very limited way we welcome the united
nations support for all nations which
are active in mali and the effort to
call up mali's interim government to
reinstall the original status
should that not work we obviously need
to re-evaluate but until then we will
remain on standby so in direct response
to the question there are no concrete
troop withdrawal plans yet all right
let's take a look at how we got here
back in 2012 twiric separatists took
over large parts of northern mali al
qaeda and isil linked fighters also
entered the region in january 2013
former colonial power france sent in
troops to remove the groups but after
struggling for nine years france
announced it would end its operation
early in 2022
recently deployed danish soldiers in
mali have been asked to leave
immediately the transitional government
said their arrival was never approved
denmark says they were invited sweden is
also part of the french operation and
announced its troops will leave in march
in germany members of parliament have
questioned the presence of the its
soldiers in mali and where they are part
of the un peacekeeping mission minisma
all right let's introduce our panel in
brussels february's portuguese chief
strategy officer at rasmussen global
in rabat nufa labud who's executive
director of the nordic center for
conflict transformation and in accra
chukwu mecca is a executive director of
the west africa network for peace
building a war welcome to all of you
gents uh chokwe mecca i'd like to start
with you
this expulsion of the french ambassador
what do you make of it
well it depends on
who you are speaking to and
how they want to contextualize the
issues
uh regarding the exposure
some people in mali have argued that it
is freedom at last
for the malians and the malian
governments
because since after the independence as
it were from the french
colonial masters
mali is assumed not have been
independent at all with regards to the
kind of influence whether the political
sphere or the economics
that the french government continue to
have
however given the huge
operations of
france in mali
there seemed to be in the short term and
even on the long term some kind of
security vacuum which is likely to be
created this could in my opinion
potentially create space for the
terrorists and armed groups to
strengthen and extend their geographical
equations
in not just the country but even in
other
spaces in in the sahara region of course
the other thing to look at is how france
will take a look at that and how that
will potentially
as it were
have consequences on regional security
coordination in the fight against
insurgencies and which could also affect
denmark's role in in france and that's
not even going to talk about the the
economic impact because at a point
when mali is facing this kind of
insurgencies which is more compounded
even with the the the coveted pandemic
they are also looking at how to lose one
of its major partners
which is uh uh france so that may even
further create serious instability uh
and economic hardship within the country
okay uh niva laboud the timeline that i
just read out was is quite interesting
is it's quite telling because in 10
years the french have failed to
eradicate the threat from insurgents the
military have taken over
russian mercenaries are moving in and
the situation well you could say it's
not got any better it's got worse
yeah definitely it's a very interesting
component that are happening in mali one
of them is now
we're looking at the french and german
reassessing their presence in in the
country what it means to me is that
first of all they're looking into some
legal basis of their presence in in the
country and the second thing is also uh
the way the reaction from the uh
government from the military shows that
uh the military is also looking for some
legal basis to renegotiate the presence
of european forces in in the country and
they even mentioned uh something in the
statement that was uh
in in the national tv that was shared in
national tv they were speaking about
how france and the uh the statements
from france actually violates the
development of friendly relations
between nations which is within the
framework of international law but also
what is important is the reaction of
friends
before that what that's trying to
europeanize the military presence in in
in mali and what is happening it was you
know
first on the intention of decrease the
presence within the barakan operation
but also push forward towards the takuba
task force which many european countries
are in it what now france is trying to
do is
they're going to need to to talk and
speak to other european countries
because both at the legal
framework is that both barack and their
presence
and presence of other european countries
in the country
have specific goals one is not only
security which is not doing well at all
but also in terms of nation building in
northern mali which we haven't seen any
any results from that and also in terms
of the political uh
structure and also in terms of
development which actually mounted the
frustration of people in mali
already
the failure
in in fulfilling the
goals of their presence and agreement
military agreements with with the
government of mali is already illegal
back legal ground for renegotiating the
the
all right the term
let's let's examine the european mission
a little bit more uh february's party
so denmark's troops ordered out germany
reconsidering its position so to france
what do you make of uh the future of
european intervention in the sahara
well uh not bright uh for the simple
reason that uh france like the united
states used to be in afghanistan
france is operating as the framework
nation uh in the mali operation
therefore if france
uh where to withdraw and not just to
reduce but to withdraw its forces the
other european contributors will not be
able to sustain their presence there so
i think this is where it comes to not so
much a military question
but a political one and and just to get
the record straight from what i've heard
from the two previous speakers
we are dealing here with
a government in bamako who is
illegitimate who has taken power by
force
who has not been elected and who is
actually partnering with not a private
security company
but a mercenary group uh which has a
track record of human rights abuse
of actually predation over natural
mineral resources
okay so we're going to come on to that
that's you're talking about this where
the problem is yeah you're talking about
the involvement of russian mercenaries
we're going to come into that to that in
just a second but but first just what
happens do you think
if there is a wholesale pull out
i mean we just heard that
potentially there's going to be this
security void which could be incredibly
dangerous but just how bad could that be
and and what would happen
well first
it depends how you define security void
because i think the one option that is
being discussed was discussed before
this political crisis was
a very light footprint quick reaction
basically pure counter-terrorism
capacity to act quickly from bases
possibly even outside mali uh to strike
at terrorist groups a bit what actually
job idol wanted to do years ago in
afghanistan so i i i think it then it
all depends and this is what the
previous speaker was saying on what the
authorities in bamako will be uh willing
uh to to to accommodate to have that and
also whether paris uh will be willing to
to work towards that kind of formula so
i think security vacuum is definitely
the option everybody
should and will want to avoid
so
then we come to the question choker
mecca that should should the french and
should the european troops stay there
well i i think again it depends on the
the mandates of on the policies of the
the eu
if you look at it on one side
just depends on the security situation
on the ground and how dangerous that's
going to be for
the country for the people and in the
region and internationally
yes that's what i'm coming to because if
you continue to say because it is an
illegitimate government which is the
truth and that your policy does not
allow you to continue to engage and
illegitimate governments especially when
they have been suspended by even the
economic community of west african
states then you may be right but if you
also look at it on the implication on
the wider implication of the spread of
the insurgents on the not just on the
sahara region but how that will also
destabilize the entire west african
region with a lot of implications for
also the european states then you may
have
made a grievous mistake of
a an exit without plan and which may
even now further complicate and compound
the entire security system that is
already established and which is also
becoming a restraint factor for the
the insurgents so what that also means
is that those countries that surround
mali especially the sahab region we
begin to experience an increase on
insurgents insurgencies especially given
the fact that burkina faso
is already under a military regime
guinea is already under military regime
there is also a lot of uh uh
street talks about the likelihood of
even could or togo uh uh also being in
the same situation very soon so nobody
knows the ripple effect of the
withdrawal this sudden withdrawal as it
were just because of the action of the
the junta okay
let's see let's bring in let's bring in
i'll come back to you in a sec but let's
bring in nafel on this so we fabrice
just mentioned afghanistan and there is
that scenario isn't there you you know
because you pour as we've seen in
afghanistan you pour as much as you like
into the region but you just keep
accumulating trouble and then the
extraction can be uh just as difficult
if not worse
mali is a little bit special case yes
for every country there is a case
perhaps you can compare a little bit
mali also with myanmar with some some
some differences but what i would like
to see here is to link one of the
elements that we are not talking about
so a lot now we're talking about a
context in which minerals found in mali
are becoming more and more important and
more and more important to many other
countries and
an example of that is the chinese
australian venture that was announced in
january 4th
by which they uh they mentioned
that they would be exploiting and they
made a final investment decision in mali
to be explained one of the largest
lithium mine perhaps in the world uh and
we know the uh lithium carbon is
actually increased for last last year
for 500
and i think that
there is some kind of deal behind the
scenes and i think that that is why the
generals actually decided that it was
worth to stick around for for for a
while
because the decision for the generals to
extend the election until uh five years
from the time when they they've been in
power is a little bit too much it's
completely different in what's happening
in other words i think uh i don't see
that there will be a security void in in
terms but i think that there will be
the chinese and the australian that will
be coming in as a replacement or some
kind of deal it will be done with the
europeans
yeah and fabrice which brings us back to
the point that you raised a little bit
earlier about the russian mercury's been
in there so this is this concept of
international involvement within mali
and we have these russian mercenaries
the wagner group and the europeans say
of course that this is incompatible
with their mission
clearly i mean this group has has
generated already enough
negative news stories in libya but also
in syria and in central african republic
uh and and
i think what they are clearly after is a
little what the previous speaker was
mentioning
securing uh key strategic resources
predating all these resources so they
are not about protecting
the malian population they might provide
a
close protection to the government
players but this is i don't know how
long they can sustain that because uh
it's not clear whether uh the current
illegitimate government can hold power
without really assuring some sort of
modicum of security to its own
population
so is it just about the the getting a
piece a slice of the mineral action if
you like but i suppose also the russians
would uh potentially expect support for
its uh positions its multilateral
positions
yes i think it's a double-edged sword on
one hand
it provides economic commercial
opportunities for
for
russian companies and at the same time
it's part of russia's
defense diplomacy which is using
its undeclared or declared military
presence to to assert its its role on
the diplomatic scene and now obviously
like in libya uh now in mali you have to
count with russia and if you want to
settle or come to a solution you will
have to have some sort of dialogue with
russia so it's obviously the means are
pretty uh
controversial and disputable but it's
true that here uh putin achieved its
goal of going where the gaps are and
being present there and then gaining a
seat at the table
chokwe mecca one senior advisor to
president macron said that the problem
centers as you've alluded to as you've
all alluded to
mali and junta breaking its commitment
to hold elections in february and then
this five year thing
and he said that trying to make all this
seem like a fight between mali and the
old colonial power is a pretty crude
trap that we won't fall into
what do you make of
that
well i think it's not just the position
of france ecowas was very clear from the
one that he said protocol on democracy
and group governance does not allow mali
to continue sustaining the the janta and
they had a roadmap which they were
supposed to respect and they brought all
kinds of issues and this has become
now making west africa as as as you
would already begin to see
a contestation of the global powers
whether it is the us the france the uk
the china the russia tokyo the gulf
states are named them for strategic
reasons you know so the presence of
russia is increasing this contestation
you know so if you reflect on what also
happened in bokina faso as soon as the
kudita uh uh took place they called for
russia you know to to to be their friend
so this has ripple effect on governance
stability and security in the region
also giving the potential consequences
on on armed race and and possible arming
of terrorists and armed groups to
destabilize the region so
it will also even weaken the regional
economic community in terms of its uh
influence and role in within the the
region
and this has its own effects
and and
newfound this continual referral to the
colonial past it's clear that it's left
a deep scar and
but in a sense at the friendship between
a rock and a hard place because they're
they're down to this day and they're
damned if they if they leave
yeah i mean
the narrative of the colon you know
kicking out the colony power is a
sentimental discourse that is used now
by the military in fact there are other
uh corey powers that are still present
in
colonized and you know africa in general
but it is a new colonialism as well by
the exploitation of the richness of the
country and the wealth of the country uh
for very specific reasons now i would
like also to to mention you know that we
don't talk about it a lot uh in within
the context in which france also has
tensed uh
relations with the with the key country
which is actually brought in mali which
is algeria and some of the questions on
uh the
how algeria is increasing the
collaboration with putin
with russia and how that actually has an
impact or influence with the within the
deployment of the russian titles within
inside mali the french intelligence says
that there is about 450 000 russian
fighters and westerners in the country
uh the some of the uh officials security
officials in mali uh they mentioned that
these wagner people are very efficient
and they can clean out the whole
northern mali within six months which is
very very ambitious so some of the
questions very very important questions
in in to what extent this idea of
non-interference in
a country's affair is actually true
especially with the key
neighboring countries to mali such as
algeria within the framework of the same
condition of
mali tension with france or colonial
power and algeria's tension with france
used in the discourse of colonialism and
to what extent that actually facilitate
the infiltration and the enabling of the
russian fighters to be present
in mali fabrice we're just running a bit
short of time but i do want to come up
with the you know talk about the
accountability of the uh current malian
government because the thing is you have
french troops you have american
intelligence gathering you have a 15 000
u.n
uh force and the marlin government is
barely in control
beyond its major cities how would they
expect to do any better without outside
assistance you wander
well that's the question and this is why
it's important not to to get the wrong
uh end of the problem the problem is not
so much france and it's uh european
international partners
but it's a government that does not have
a plan forward that clearly is just
about leaving uh the day after tomorrow
uh with the protection of of russian
mercenaries and i think that this is
really the uh the the the sad kind of
outcome of almost 10 years of of
presence by france and its partners but
but let me just make a point on that
this is the conundrum and this is the
kind of afghanistan conundrum that means
france came with the best intention at
the invitation of the local authorities
to prevent
a complete collapse of the the malian
state and government against chief's
groups
and but with you know years of presence
and so on even though the best intention
france also became de facto part of the
problem and even though it's not there
as a colonial power i think the colonial
actors are much more the wagner group
than anyone else uh it is now
increasingly perceived and presented as
part of this problem and this is exactly
what we saw in afghanistan where the
international coalition came to solve a
specific problem try to build a real
afghan government and at the end we're
seeing as much part of the problem as
other issues in the country so this is
the risk of foreign intervention and we
are paying the cost now
uh chokwe america do you think there's
any way out of this do you think there
will be a way for the european
europeans to maintain uh their mission
in mali given all the problems that
we've been
analyzing and assessing you know the
russian mercenaries or the illegitimate
government as you call it
clearly mali lacks the capacity to
address the
multi-dimensional security challenges
facing the country
and therefore moving
out
of france or the eu under this
circumstance
will not really solve the problem i
think
rather
france should continue to engage with
ecowas it should be a gradual
process through
cooperation and dialogue
in order to tap into the the
opportunities that the french or the eu
provide to enhance some level of
resilience of the country as against the
growing insecurity in the country and
and the region so i think that there
should be uh honest conversation between
eu on one hand and then a coast and
perhaps african union on the other part
and even if it means involving the u.n
system to see how
this can be um
better handled even under the
circumstance
all right
gents we'll have to leave it there we
run out of time chuckway mecca it's
great to have you with us thanks very
much indeed fabulous portia and newfall
abood thanks very much indeed and i
thank you too for watching you can see
this program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page uh that's facebook.com forward
slash aj inside story and you can also
join in the conversation on twitter our
handle for that is at aj inside story
from me nick clark and the whole team
here it is